formamos un acuerdo para atacar al
cambio climático detuvimos al regular
antes de que se convirtiera una pandemia
todos heredó una economía creciente y un
mundo más fácil y como todo lo demás que
era lo llevó a la bancarrota cuando este
presidente va al exterior
es una vergüenza le escribe cartas de
moros de dictadores y ataca a nuestros
aliados no necesitamos un presidente del
cual la gente se esté riendo y que
pretenda que rusia no ataca con nuestras
elecciones ahora en la cena no hace nada
cuando rusia poner recompensas por las
cabezas de nuestras tropas no sabe cómo
defender nuestras tropas solamente le
interesa defenderse a sí mismo este es
el punto nuestros intereses nuestros
ideales y nuestros hombres y mujeres
valientes en uniforme no pueden
permitirse otros cuatro años de donald
church nuestras tropas no pueden salirse
de esas zonas peligrosas y escondiéndose
en un búnker como lo hace donald trump
se necesita un presidente que los apoye
y el presidente baiden lo hará
en la brújula moral de bailén siempre ha
apuntado en la dirección correcta
luchando contra la parte en la lucha
para despertar al mundo del 2 por el
genocido de los balcanes él comprende
que ninguno de los problemas de este
mundo ni las armas nucleares ni
construir reconstruir después del coven
y el terrorismo y claramente no la
crisis climática ninguna de esos temas
puede ser resuelto sin unir a las
naciones la fortaleza con fortaleza y
con multas yo comprende nuestros valores
y no significa el comprende que no se
puede llevar la democracia alrededor del
mundo si no la prácticas en casa y él
sabe que incluso en estados unidos de
américa necesita amigos en este planeta
antes de donald trump hablábamos de el
excepcionalismo estadounidense lo único
excepcional de la política en coherente
de hecho es que ha hecho que nuestra
nación que además aislada que nunca
antes
joe biden sabe que somos excepcionales
por
somos excepcionales porque hacemos cosas
excepcionales en el 6 de julio de 1944
jóvenes estadounidenses dieron sus vidas
en las calles de normandía para liberar
al mundo de la tiranía y de esa guerra
creamos la paz y reconstruimos el mundo
y ese fue y sigue siendo algo
excepcional es lo opuesto de todo lo que
donald trump defiende este momento es un
momento para luchar por la seguridad de
estados unidos y del mundo solamente joe
biden puede hacer que estados unidos
lidere como estados unidos de nuevo
existen de acuerdo envíen el joint al 30
330 gracias